my viral tick tock got me a record deal
and this is that story
my name is lynn lapid and this all
started in the summer
of 2019. i was 16. i really loved music
and i was just
kind of casually putting covers on
youtube and some conan gray songs
just very bedroom pop nobody really saw
them it took me eight months to get to
100 subscribers
then i started posting on tick tock and
instagram and that's when things started
to really pick up within a few months i
reached 10 000 followers on instagram
then one day my dad was messaged by
producer he said that he was
this big well-known producer that's
worked with a lot of
big artists we started talking he was a
lot more
pop upbeat groovy i guess but that's not
my vibe so
i just thought we didn't click that way
i was expressing that i didn't
want to work with him i think he got a
bit defensive
and was starting to tell me that i
wouldn't make it in the industry if i
didn't follow his advice
i was like really sad for a couple days
i was looking at my own music and i
thought that none of it was good enough
i started to question would it be silly
of me to even consider
trying to go into the music industry if
this guy who's
worked with so many successful artists
tells me that i wouldn't make it
if i try to do it my way then an idea
came to me i started to imagine
like a world or reality where i followed
his advice
and i did get big and famous like he
said i realized that i would be unhappy
and so i made a story
out of it and i made it into a song she
was only
17 when pretty sermon came offering that
all her dreams would come true
as soon as i finished the first verse i
posted it to tick tock the very same day
and it blew up
and my account was growing like crazy i
was getting like
10 000 followers every couple of hours
so then republic records reached out to
me
at the time i didn't really know what
republic was and i googled them
i was like oh my gosh ariana grande is
under them and so is taylor swift
the weeknd all these big artists i was
hesitant to talk to any labels
at all because of my experience with
producer man it took a lot of time
to you know trust so i was connected
with this producer and i found out that
he was conan gray's producer
and started working out different
versions
of producer man what she couldn't see
was he was in it for the money
[Music]
12 days after releasing it it got to 1
million streams
i just wanted to thank everybody who
supported me and gave me words of
encouragement
and if the real producer man is watching
right now i'd like to thank you
i think without you telling me that i
wouldn't make it then i probably
wouldn't be
here right now
[Music]
you